und in mainz begrüße ich ganz herzlich
den aus experten michael lüders am 1
schönen tag hallo elias die saudis haben
heute erklärt catan müsse ihre
bedingungen und die der anderen
arabischen staaten erfüllen werden sie
das tun
naja carter als einer sehr schwierigen
situation das land wird massiv erpresst
es wird letztendlich den saudischen
forderungen auf die ein oder andere
weise nachkommen müssen
aber es ist schon ein sehr tragisches
schauspiel das sich hier abspielt wer
vor wenigen tagen noch gedacht hätte
dass es so ein vorfall geben könnte
ausgerechnet katar ein pro westliches
konservatives land unter druck gesetzt
wie ein schurkenstaat geradezu er hätte
das wahrscheinlich nicht für möglich
gehalten und nun haben wir eine solche
situation ist es ein showdown vor allem
zwischen saudi arabien und dem iran
darum geht s katar wird vorgeworfen zu
enge beziehungen zu teheran zu
unterhalten aber kaká hat gar keine
andere möglichkeiten als dieses zu tun
denn gemeinsam beuten katar und der iran
das weltweit größte erdgasfeld im
persischen golf aus dann geben wir uns
um eine einschätzung wie ernst ist diese
krise das neue dimension ich meine es ja
nicht der erste konflikt dieser
größenordnung auf dem diplomatischen
quellen nein in der tat nicht aber dies
hat schon eine neue qualität weil ja
hier golf kooperations mitglieder
gegenseitig in stellung gehen das ist
ungefähr so auf die ebene der
europäischen union übertragen als würde
deutschland die grenzen zu frankreich
schließen und forderungen in richtung
paris richten oder in richtung der
niederlande
das würde man inhalte eu kaum tun aber
dort ist es nun geschehen und das würde
die saudische führung niemals tun ohne
rückendeckung aus washington
es ist ganz interessant zu sehen dass
gestern us-präsident trump ganz stolz
getwittert hat dass sein besuch in saudi
arabien vor zwei wochen maßgeblich dazu
beigetragen habe dass man saudi arabien
gegenüber katar klartext rede
heute nun ist die amerikanische
diplomatie bemühte diese
twitter-meldungen abzufedern
aber im kern ist es wohl so dass dieser
besuch von präsident farm in sao dies
den rücken gestärkt hat sie haben 410
milliarden dollar waffen eingekauft um
glaubt man in riad
ein showdown angehen zu können in
richtung iran
das ist eine sehr gefährliche strategie
weil jederzeit eine solche eskalation in
konfrontation münden kann
und das ist angesichts der ohnehin recht
hoch explosiven lage in der region
denken wir nur an syrien irak und
jemanden nicht wirklich eine gute
nachricht aber noch mal in richtung iran
es gibt das atom abkommen was barack
obama drums vorgänger mit organisiert
hat das als großen diplomatischen erfolg
natürlich gefeiert hat von dem
republikaner dafür natürlich verachtet
wird ist donald trump jetzt ein
schwacher präsident dass die saudis
becken jetzt haben sie freie hand
herr präsident ist in erster linie und
kluger präsident weil er den
diplomatischen spielraum im umgang mit
saudi arabien vollkommen eingeschränkt
hat die usa lassen sich gegenwärtig wenn
man so will vor den karren einer
saudisch inspirierten macht politik
gegenüber dem iran einspannen
das erfolgt sehr zur freude saudi
arabien und auch israels aber es braucht
natürlich die usa ihre diplomatischen
möglichkeiten und niemand ist ernsthaft
bereit jedenfalls nicht auf die ebene
der europäischen union das 2015 vor zwei
jahren geschlossene atom abkommen mit
dem iran in frage zu stellen oder wieder
eine politik der harten hand gegenüber
teheran zu verfolgen
aber es könnte durchaus passieren dass
jetzt der showdown zwischen saudi
arabien und dem iran an läuft der sich
sowieso schon im konflikt in syrien
gezeigt hat die saudis wollen den sturz
von baschar al assad und die iraner
unterstützen ihn
und nun gehen die konflikte in eine neue
runde das ist alles sehr beunruhigend
weil es so unberechenbar ist was hier in
irrationalität zu beobachten ist
nun werden die saudis den kataris die
unterstützung der terroristen vor sind
beileibe aber selbst kein kind von
traurigkeit was das angeht
was heißt das für den konflikt zwischen
schiiten und sunniten er nicht zuletzt
im jemen auch seinen niederschlag findet
ginge es vielleicht über den jemen
dass man da zu einer sagen immer
beruhigung käme nein leider ist die lage
im jemen sehr dramatisch sehr tragisch
der dortige krieg wird hier kaum
wahrgenommen obwohl dort
tausende menschen vom hungertod bedroht
sind es ist dieses ein völlig sinnloser
von saudi arabien entfesselter krieg in
der absicht dort den iran militärisch
herauszufordern dem mann vorwirft die
sogenannten hus die rebellen zu
unterstützen
es gibt dafür aber keine wirklich
überzeugenden beweise saudi arabien
leistet sich zahlreiche kriege und wir
unterstützen die saudis beispielsweise
auch zahlreiche die akustische
oppositionelle in syrien das alles
überfordert in wirtschaftlicher hinsicht
saudi arabien ganz massiv aber man
glaubt rückenwind zu haben aus
washington und der konflikt zwischen
sunniten und schiiten die wir
angesprochen haben
der wird in der tat massiv gefördert es
gibt nicht per se konflikt zwischen
sunniten und schiiten aber die
instrumentalisierung der machtpolitik
mit hilfe der religion ist sehr
gefährlich geworden saudi arabien
finanziert und unterstützt den radikalen
sunnitischen islam
auch in form von al kaida oder den
taliban und das ist keine gute
entwicklung umgekehrt und radikale
schiiten dabei in syrien im irak die
dortigen machthaber zu unterstützen und
das ist natürlich auch keine gute
entwicklung und viele menschen haben
große angst davor wie sich das alles
weiter entwickeln könnte es ist ein
spiel mit dem feuer
die religiösen gefühle der menschen über
die grenzen hinweg anzuheizen haben die
sorge dass damit auch mit dieser
momentanen krise und einer möglichen
zuspitzung die anti es koalition
gefährdet ist nein die anti es koalition
die wird ihre arbeit fortsetzen auch aus
iranischer sicht wird man jetzt nach dem
terroranschlag heute in teheran
umso nachdrücklicher alles daran setzen
die den islamischen staat militärisch zu
besiegen aber das problem ist ja die
zeit danach der islamische staat ist
militärisch in der defensive er reagiert
auf seine weise mit verstärkten
terroranschlägen unter anderem in europa
zuletzt in großbritannien und heute eben
im iran und dieses wird sicherlich noch
zu nehmen
diese intensivierung der terror
anschläge außerhalb des eigentlichen
einflussbereiches im irak und in syrien
und die konflikte in der region sind ja
keineswegs befriedet weder im irak noch
in syrien und mit präsident ford haben
wir nun
eine neue konstellation in washington es
gibt dort offenbar einflussreiche
machtzentren die noch immer auf
konfrontation mit dem iran setzen und
das ist ein sehr ungutes omen
die gesamte region befindet sich in
einer hochexplosiven lage unter genug da
genügt ein funke um in der tat dieses
ganze fast in die luft zu jagen ist
völlig unberechenbar was in der region
passiert vor einer woche hätte niemand
geglaubt dass innerhalb von 24 stunden
die golfstaaten ihre beziehungen zu
katar abbrechen die meisten jedenfalls
und das land diplomatisch völlig
isolieren es ist aber geschehen und wer
weiß was in zwei wochen oder in drei
monaten in der region passiert ein
sorgenvoller michael herzlichen dank
vielen dank